morning to you the government has made a
u-turn on visas for foreign hgv drivers
as it takes action to contain the
growing supply crisis gripping the
nation's petrol stations the transport
secretary announced short-term visas for
5 000 foreign drivers as well as special
funding to train up to four thousand new
drivers
but industry insiders are warning that
things could still get worse in the
short term as the mass panic buying of
fuel across the country shows no signs
of stopping belena veselinovich reports
[Music]
the government says they finally have an
answer to this
queues for petrol as far as the eye can
see caused by a shortage of drivers to
deliver it triggering some to panic by
i think it's a lot of it is people being
greedy with the fuel bit like the toilet
roll situation they're just that greed
they don't give that damn about
emergency services
people essential carers that need you
they just think about themselves you
know i work for the nhs and i still need
to get fuel to get to work
now the government says 4 000 people
will get free intensive training for an
agv license with mod examiners providing
extra tests and immigration rules
relaxed to allow 5 000 haulers from
abroad to plug the urgent need
but some say foreign drivers won't be
easily tempted to come
it all depends what the wages are if the
money's right to entice people to come
over here move them away from their
families for
essentially a short period of time
i personally
can't really see it working but
the proof's in the pudding
as pumps since some forecourts run dry
there's pressure to find quick solutions
this is the second petrol station on
this road that's run out of fuel staff
say they're expecting a delivery but
they don't know when or what type of
fuel it will be
transport secretary grant shap said the
industry must continue to improve
conditions to retain new drivers
but with the shortage so severe some are
warning it could be six months before
new government measures take effect
some of the things that are being done
will help
it's questionable as to how quickly
they're going to be able to apply so
we're talking about immediate fixes
and i think
it's very difficult to tell how
that will
actually plug the gap of 100 000
[Music]
hdv drivers short
until that gap is plugged supply issues
like these are likely to continue
milena vaselinovich sky news
well lover birchley's in central london
for us this morning it seems emma the
message is if you think you're going out
looking for petrol don't bother because
frankly everywhere seems to be shut
yeah certainly on my drive here i saw
about six petrol stations and there
wasn't a drop of fuel at any of them and
we know that there was signs up at the
start of the m4 saying
no fuel at the services heading
westbound
and overnight petrol stations that were
closed they get a delivery and then you
start seeing the cues so we've got some
pictures
from half past four this morning at a
petrol station uh in west london where
people were queuing up and inevitably
when they hear there is fuel people keep
coming they're blocking the roads
causing uh all sorts of uh confusion
for the traffic around there so you know
it can change when a delivery comes but
the fact is is it's very very unsure at
the moment and now we're getting details
of the contingency plans from the
government
which it's hoped will start to ease it
so as was reported yesterday 5 000
temporary visas which will allow uh
drivers from outside the uk to come in
that would start from
next month and right up until christmas
eve also those four thousand extra lorry
drivers that are going to be trained up
some new investment from that but also
existing education budgets which will be
used as part of that and the mod helping
with examiners which should mean
thousands more tests are taken over the
next 12 weeks and quite interestingly uh
this uh
news we're hearing of
close to a million letters which will
land on the doormats of people with hgv
licenses trying to lure them back into
the business with promises of more money
of better working conditions flexible
hours
fixed hours if if that's what you want
so trying to get a stronger domestic
workforce that is going to make sure
that there aren't supply problems but we
are three months away from christmas uh
we know that temporary visas have also
been granted to 5
500 poultry workers just as
they were granted to help fruit pick
during the summer it's all trying to
keep things moving but time is ticking
for christmas and in the short term you
know people are driving around we're
seeing people coming up here pulling up
going asking where the fuel is people
slowing down just checking it's the same
everywhere as people try to find fuel
many people who desperately need it for
their work or to visit family
okay emma thank you let's talk to rob
holliman director of young's
transportation
and logistics good to see you this
morning look
these temporary visas 5000 people coming
in and the letters going out to a
million people with who
not working but have hgv licenses is it
going to make much of a difference and
quickly
morning um i i fear not you know and as
is normal with this this government and
many preceding governments is is far too
little too late um
we reckon and the rha you know the the
trade barney reckon that there's
somewhere around 20 to 25 000 drivers
that left our shores at the end of last
year and haven't returned so we're
talking about a fifth or twenty percent
of those drivers that we need
need back being granted visas so what
about the other 80 and why couldn't it
be you know the 25 000 visas i don't
understand why they've limited it to
five
um
forgive me but i mean it's you know that
that adds something to the equation five
thousand at least four thousand uh new
drivers qualified pretty quickly
hopefully in all of this and and and
former drivers being invited to come
back i mean it's a there's a whole
package doesn't it make a difference
no i i i think there's there's a couple
of red herrings in there um it says that
they're going to be training up 4 000
drivers well we've got somewhere in the
region of 40 000 drivers that are
trained up that are waiting to take the
test it's not more training that's the
immediate problem is getting these tests
taken that's the immediate problem
um so the the writing to a million
drivers
let's be honest you know those billion
drivers have heard all about the
salaries that are being banded around if
they wanted to come back into the
industry i i suspect they'd have come
back in now if they could but what
nobody's mentioning with these million
letters is there's a requirement for
them to have a certificate of
professional competence
they have to sit for 35 hours in a
classroom every five years
a lot of drivers have retired or left
the industry have let that lapse so
before they can sit behind the wheel
they'll need to get 35 hours in a
classroom behind them
which will cost them anything between
300 and 800 pounds so it's not as simple
as just writing to them saying come back
to the industry i've been saying and as
as the rha let's give a dispensation to
people to say look the cpc if if you
retired or left the industry in the last
year or 12 months 18 months or
two years
then you're you're able to you can be
able to come back into it without having
a cepc for six months maybe 12 months i
don't know we could have a set period
just to get us through this crisis
because the crisis is what we've got
yeah yeah when you talk about the salary
is being banded about i mean he he's
going to pay for that is that going to
fall down to the likes of of your
company to find more money to pay these
people well it's going to be it's going
to be you and me that pay pay pay these
increases because it's going to filter
down to the end user you know
the companies that are paying the
enormous salaries and we're here in 60s
and 70s and 80 000 pounds a year for
goodness sake they are the supermarkets
now how factual those those salaries are
and bait all based on what i can't tell
you but if we're going into salaries of
that re that sort of region then that's
going to reflect on the the end user
which is you and me buying the product
at the supermarket i mean you mentioned
so too little too late i mean it's a
cliche in a way but
but but even even if everything went to
plan even if everything the government
is has laid out worked and worked
beautifully
how long does that leave us before
things
are improving on the roads
i i i don't think you'll notice much
difference with what there's planned so
far i really don't i'm sorry to be so
pessimistic
and i'm not one of those that seem to
scare mongering or shouting and
screaming it's it's it's not it's not
that simple it is a simple solution but
they're not adopting it the simple
solution is five times as many visas
it's get these tests done seven days a
week twenty hours a day drivers drive at
night why not have a test at night um
it's giving support to the industry for
young drivers who the insurance
companies want massive premiums for
under 25s or for those that haven't been
driving for two years the government
could underwrite those those additional
premiums um that would get help get
young people back into industry but what
everyone seems to
neatly sweep under the carpet is us the
general public
are treat drivers with contempt we do
whether we intend to or not we do
15 months ago these guys were hailed as
haulage heroes they were effectively
risking their lives by going into places
where they knew nothing about the pro
they covered protocols they could be
great but they could be diabolical so
they actually were going in blind
our shelves remained full
obviously you had the ridiculous panic
buying that we've got of petrol now we
had that at the beginning of the coving
crisis surely we all remember that where
toilet rolls were disappearing off the
shelves and could you know that's what
i'm passing for some reason or other
these are the same people i suspect
trying to get the petrol now which is
just selfish and totally inconsiderate
but these guys were haulage heroes now
we you know we're down the road a bit
and forgive the pun but but they're
turning up at premises and being told no
you can't use their facilities it's
staff only the there's far too few truck
stops in the uk we've been campaigning
for that the rha as well for years
and the ones that there are the
conditions are at best
barely adequate and at worst downright
disgusting so little wonder that we
can't attract people into this industry
okay rob good to talk to you this
morning thank you
you're welcome
now secure stampers watered down
proposals for changing labour's rule
book will be put to the party conference
in brighton following a bruising
internal row he's faced opposition from
unions and labour's left at proposals
which would have dramatically increased
mp's influence in the election of a new
leader now despite concessions and some
pretty big ones zakir has managed to put
a revised shake-up of labour rules to a
vote which is expected later on today
our chief political correspondent john
craig reports
he's no longer leader but jeremy corbyn
is still the darling of the labour left
and now he's spearheading the left's
opposition to sakia stammer's party
reforms you've got some degree of
consensus on what we're doing and how
we're doing where we're going to
if you then tear all that up
and say we're going to manage the
economy we're going to reduce
expectations and concentrate instead on
rule changes within the labour party i
really struggle to understand how this
is going to mobilize or motivate people
to come to labor in order to defeat this
tory government i am desperate to get
rid of this tory government
mr corbyn's former trade union
cheerleader len mccluskey promoting his
memoirs in brighton after his recent
retirement is also condemning sakir's
proposals unfortunately this is a pretty
naked attempt to try to reduce
members input into the democracy of our
party
i'm sad that kia is supporting it but it
doesn't surprise me and i hope they get
voted down on day two of labour's
conference zakir wants to move on to
promoting the party's policies with
announcements on climate change housing
schools and online safety
but they're in danger of being
overshadowed by the rule changed row
today the battle over sakiya stama's
contentious proposals to rewrite the
labour party rule book moves from
meetings behind closed doors to the
conference floor where the decisive vote
on the plans takes place this afternoon
zakir's shadow cabinet allies claim the
reforms are vital for labour
we're trying to do something really
important this week which is to get the
labour party ready to win a general
election that's about making sure our
organisation's in shape and to make sure
we've got a vision for the country that
inspires people and wins that trust one
of the problems with the last set of
reforms that that were brought in is
that it especially allowed a situation
where
you can get elected by 20 000 labour
voters
and then a handful of activists the next
week could give you your marching orders
but mr corbyn and his supporters are not
giving up the fight
[Applause]
john craig sky news brighton
our political joe pike is in brighton
for us this morning look joe i mean
these modified reforms going to the
floor this afternoon what happens to
security doesn't win this
uh i think it would be an embarrassment
but normally the labour party conference
stephen they wouldn't push for a vote on
the conference floor if they didn't
think they could win it and it's not a
normal vote of party members half of the
votes come from unions half of the votes
come from constituency
delegates therefore the leadership
seemed pretty confident but sakir is
definitely wishing hoping praying he can
pivot now to policy one senior
ally of his told me last night this was
messy but a win a win for a number of
reasons that john craga set out in his
report the pivot to policy will partly
be on education and on private schools
kiestama does want to
end tax breaks for private schools they
currently have a charitable status
they're exempt from vat and business
rates and the labour leader believes
that by ending all of that if he is
elected prime minister he could make 1.7
billion pounds and that could partly be
put to help school leavers and ensure
that they are prepared for the workplace
and have better career guidance one
possibly bad headline that could
distract from all of that
is angela rayner angerena made some
comments at a drinks reception last
night here in brighton and made some
controversial comments about the
conservative party saying we cannot get
any worse than a bunch of scum
homophobic racist misogynistic absolute
pile of banana republic etonian piece of
scum that i've ever seen in my life she
did insist she held back a little god
knows what she'd have said if she hadn't
but the conservatives are already
calling for her to apologize and i think
today angela reyna and some of her
senior labour colleagues could be asked
difficult questions about those comments
those comments of course aimed at a
loyal left-wing labour audience but are
is that the sort of right antenna and
tone when actually they're really trying
to persuade uh people in previous
elections who voted conservative lib dem
and the snp to now stephen vote labour
okay
joe thank you
now anthony joshua has failed to retain
his heavyweight titles after being
beaten by ukraine's alexander usyk in a
12-round fight in north london hannah's
got all the details for us this morning
yes stephen it was a devastating defeat
for anthony joshua as he lost his
heavyweight world titles to ukraine's
alexander yusick who takes joshua's wba
ibf and wbo heavyweight titles on points
at the tottenham hotspur stadium music
won the sensational fight by a unanimous
decision after what was a truly
scintillating performance the judges
scored the 517-112
116-112 and 115-113
all in favor of usyk he becomes only the
third boxer to win world titles at
cruiserweight and heavyweight and it's
the second defeat of joshua's career
after he was beaten by andy ruiz jr back
in 2019 he got his belts back though in
the rematch of that one it does though
ruined joshua's hopes of the dream all
british undisputed title fight against
tyson fury who again faces deontay
wilder on october the 9th big question
this morning was was the result a
surprise it wasn't really a shock
because the unbeaten ukrainian music is
a former undisputed world cruise
cruiserweight champion
hello thank you now germany will choose
a new leader today as angela merkel bows
out as chancellor after 16 years polling
stations have just opened
with
excuse me with provisional results
expected in the early hours of tomorrow
morning let's show you what's happening
in munich
where the poles hold a short time ago
oh it doesn't appear to be anybody there
yet um
but there you go um
it's not the most gripping it's not the
most gripping picture is it um but never
mind that voting is underwear and it is
a very tight race
this one it is there will be a coalition
as a result of all of this the big
question is who is going to be end up
being chancellor will it be
uh angela merkel's chosen successor from
the cdu who really doesn't have a lot of
of popularity it has to be said he's
quite unpopular figure
or will it be um
oh there's someone going in to vote
there you go
um
the other candidates who are seen as
much more charismatic even the potential
leader of the green party i mean they're
training in third place in the polls at
the moment but possibility that she may
be able to step in as chancellor all
part of the negotiations which will
happen depending on when that what that
result is if we will get provisional
results tomorrow
a book of condolence has been opened at
a community center in kidbrook giving
people the chance to send messages to
the family of teacher sabina nessa the
28 year old was murdered as she walked
to meet a friend at a pub just five
minutes from her home in southeast
london
these three people have died after a
train derailed in north central montana
a spokesman for rail firm amtrak said
five cars of the empire builder train
which runs between chicago and seattle
derailed near joplin
now there have been more evacuations on
the island of la palma where a volcano
has been erupting for a week now the
airport has been closed emergency
services have had to retreat because of
ongoing explosions which are sending a
thick plume of smoke into the air
becky cottrell reports
[Music]
this red hot lava is a sign that things
are getting worse
it continues to pour down the
mountainside in slow but terrifying
streams
these houses are empty those who lived
here were evacuated like thousands of
others on the island who've left homes
they fear they'll never see again
everyone here is waiting wondering when
the eruptions will stop and how much
damage they'll do before then
i'm very very worried about the
situation of the ash
because the ash is blanketing the
neighborhood
it's been a disaster for all the plants
animals and all the buildings
the volcano has been emitting molten
rock and toxic ash for almost a week
[Music]
and the explosions have become more
intense the pressure inside creating a
new vent to the outside
the two openings the two mouths as you
normally say ended up merging into just
one mouth through which yesterday
afternoon and night the new lava flew
and settled above the old lava
how long will it carry on for the
experts can't be sure we cannot have a
statistic
we cannot go to the absolute number of
days or weeks because we have some
eruptions that lasted nine nine days but
to have another eruption in las vegas
that lasted years
so in la palma the eruptions actually i
mean the known eruption the historical
eruption the last 500 years uh have a
duration of about 20 days and 80 days
but this is not the rule
la palmas airport is closed because of a
giant ash cloud traces of it everywhere
and as the cleanup operation continues
the island prepares to take in the full
scale of the destruction becky kochel
sky news la palma
now if one marathon sounds like hard
work to you and yes it does sparrow
thought for 28 year old ella rothwell
who's just done six in six days to raise
money for calm the campaign against
living miserably ella jones is now from
bristol good to see you this morning the
most important thing here i guess is to
talk about why you decided to do this
your motivation
um good morning
yes i did it predominantly in memory of
my little brother but also to raise
awareness and start a conversation about
mental health that i feel is
not being had as much as it could be
i mean what what happened with with
freddie i mean
clearly
you know close siblings um were you
aware of the struggles he was going
through
we really weren't and it came completely
out of the blue but in april
uh 2019 he took his own life
and
none of us saw it coming he was a very
vivacious
loving
gorgeous person and we didn't expect it
at any point so it was a huge shock and
a huge loss for our family
i can't even
bear to think about it really i mean so
what does calm do what what are
what are their aims i mean the campaign
against living miserably is one thing
but is it about young men in particular
sort of opening up and being able to
express their feelings
well karma doing amazing work with
providing phone lines
um for anybody who is in need so
most of the money that i have fundraised
with this run will go to keeping phone
lines open so people can
call um and have somebody external to
speak to when they're feeling at their
lowest point or just if they need to
speak about how they're feeling to
someone who they don't know and don't
judge but they are also doing amazing
things for
families who are bereaved through
suicide and they um
offer lots of support in that way too so
they're just a fantastic charity
i mean i know you decided to take on
this
ridiculous task with the aim of raising
five grand you you've well surpassed
that haven't you
yeah we're really nearly at 30 000
pounds which is phenomenal and beyond
all my wildest expectations
um but everyone has been so generous
especially through this week
and
the support has been incredible and
we've got nearly 30 000 pounds so
it's really really great
and it will make a big difference i'm
sure to to calm um look
six marathons in six days how
how was it from day one to day six
so i actually have got a queried stress
fracture in my foot now so the last
marathon was cycled
but from the very beginning um
it was
just
it almost didn't feel real it just felt
like i've got i've got to do this i've
got to get the miles in and i ran all
along um the
canal path from the thames to
down through to bristol so it was
beautiful all the way
i did feel slightly insane but
it was fun i really enjoyed it
and and
i mean it clearly involves spending a
fair amount of time
in your own thoughts doing something
like this i would imagine does that
what did you do did you were you
thinking about freddie on the way or
part of the way i mean it must
it must give you given your chance to
reflect
it really did i took freddie was
known for wearing beanie hats so i had
his beanie in my backpack the entire way
and um
i
it was a lovely opportunity to
feel like i could take him with me on
what i was doing and i think running has
been huge for my mental health over
locked down and has helped me heal and
has helped me grieve
since losing fred hence why i started
doing it because i'm not a natural
runner um
so
yeah it's been
it's been a really
great process and i took him with me the
whole way
yeah yeah i bet you did um look really
good to talk to you ella thanks very
much indeed if you're affected by
any issues rather you just need to talk
to someone now there are various people
you can get in touch with calm i know
that ella's been fundraising for you go
to the calm zone
and uh and
contact them that way and that obviously
is particularly linked to to suicide and
and and the families of those people
who've died through suicide so they
might be a great place to reach out to
or of course you can speak to the
samaritans
and they will again listen to you
without any sort of judgment
116123 is their phone number or you can
email joe at samaritans.org
now let's see what the weather's going
to do for you good news and bad news
today there is going to be warm sunshine
but wet and windy weather is moving in
and that's going to sort of change it
over the next week to sort of cooler
more unsettled conditions so mild cloudy
start bit of drizzle this morning
rain and gusty winds moving into western
ireland much of britain will be fine
with some warm sunny spells just a small
risk of heavy showers in southeast
england but it is going to turn windy
across ireland northern ireland western
scotland as that rain pushes eastwards
with some heavy bursts of rain
time for the papers then this morning
with anne diamond and michael booker
good to see you both again and let's
start with the sunday times should we
looking at wind farms
yes but this is a wind farm and a solar
farm in morocco um i mean obviously we
know that we're facing a bit of an
energy crisis could get worse we've got
electricity companies going out of
business and what have you well the
former chief executive of tesco a guy
called sir dave lewis who apparently
used to be known as drastic dave has
come up with quite a drastic solution um
and basically he's bought or he wants to
buy this enormous area the size of
greater london in morocco in north um
north africa
and um where there is uninterrupted
sunshine and wind apparently so it's the
perfect place to put a solar and wind
farm um and so he wants to build uh that
solar and wind farm there and then have
a giant long cable that's going to be
something like 70 000
kilometers long going all the way um
basically from morocco all the way down
past spain and up past the french coast
and and into britain
um which seems amazing but i suppose
they do put these sort of cables down
don't they and he reckons it will
provide free energy to about seven
million homes in britain by the end of
the decade the only job is he hasn't got
enough money to actually do it himself
it's cost it to be 16 million pounds
which actually sounds very cheap doesn't
it
but he's asking boris johnson for the
money to be able to do it uh so far
hasn't had much luck but it does sound
like a very good entrepreneurial idea it
does just i saw something once about if
you if you put solar farms in in the
sahara desert you don't need a very big
area to be able to generate enough power
for the whole planet apparently
but how you get it
how you get it there is another matter
it's lots of cabling isn't it
exactly how to get it there and how you
get the energy back just with these long
cables all at the bottom of the sea i
don't know yeah
to the sunday people michael looking at
marcus rashford
yeah well on the front of uh some
newspapers we've got the leader of the
uh the labour movement the labour party
uh given setting out their stall uh and
so is kirstarma oh no but uh no marcus
rashford who's the many thing is the
real leader of the labour party these
days and the man who gets things done uh
rather than politicians he's demanding
that they act the 20 pound benefit
caught the universal credit card that's
coming up in october now you know he's
got he has got a good track record with
the changing the minds of the government
as he did with the the school dinners
last year and it just shows you how
effective you know activism is at the
moment from various celebrities if they
hit the right cause whereas you know if
you if you look at someone like kirsten
when you look at the labour party and
the way that there is this infighting
dominating people are getting a bit
tired of that and when they see someone
like marcus rashford a successful
footballer who's
come up from fairly humble beginnings
and is now trying to make a difference
you can see where people are having
their heads turned by people like him
and interestingly in uh starman's stuff
in the sunday mirror he's talking about
getting rid of universal credit
altogether at some point so um they
might want to have a bit of a
conversation because uh marcus seems to
be leading it at the moment yeah yeah
there's something about him he does it
for such a young man he does have a lot
of credibility you have to say
um to the sunday express and um looking
at i you know i have to be honest i
don't like this christmas this whole
talk about christmas yet it's too early
it's too early
but we all want to think about christmas
now and and when we i mean this time
last year we were only just beginning to
come to terms with the fact that maybe
christmas would be ruined and i was in
total denial over it i thought no no
there's absolutely no way nothing's
going to stop me having a family
christmas and it didn't happen and the
worst thing is that if we don't get our
act together and get more lorry drivers
on the roads and start to free up
business again um then we may well find
that we are in lockdown by default
that's what some uh politicians are
predicting and lockdown by default
really means that it's the government's
fault
last year was covered there was nothing
else maybe that could be done but this
year
these shortages these problems should
have been predicted months and months
ago many people are saying um and that
frankly it's the fault of the government
if we have to endure a christmas that is
effectively locked down again simply
because we can't travel we haven't got
the fuel we can't get the stuff oh it's
depressing isn't it it is depressing i'm
going to start i don't know about you
mick i'm going to start freezing my
sprouts now
in preparation
why not
um what's this in your paper about dry
cleaners
well absolutely fascinating this and it
shows you what a nation of scruffs we've
become
because uh there's about 2 000 dry
cleaners have gone bossed uh in the last
uh 18 months simply because we're not
wearing those you know those fancy
clothes you know the shirt market
apparently has gone down 70 now there's
the old jerry seinfeld joke uh about the
warning label on dry cleaning only claws
is the only label that humans actually
respect so we're all going to have all
this stuff knocking around the house how
many of you ever have you ever done that
have you ever tried to wash clothes dry
clean only and put it in a washing
machine it's like russian roulette now
these people we used to hand over this
stuff to them it was covered in whatever
you give it to them to put them in that
big magical machine that didn't seem to
have anything in it whatsoever tumbled
it out a bit next thing you know it came
back shrink wrapped in plastic perfect
again not smelling of anything looking
great these people are magicians and we
should be paying them more and we're
gonna we're gonna this country is gonna
be at a loss once people start wearing
suits and nice dresses again and going
back to work because the dry cleaners
have gone oh go online
i wonder if we will go back to wearing
quite such formal clothes as we did
before i mean the death of the shirt is
a good thing we should have we should
have killed off the shirt years ago um i
mean all of the ironing and pressing
that goes into chirp wearing is
ridiculous so i'm beginning to think
that maybe even if maybe we do go back
to the office um we'll we'll accept a
much more liberal sort of easy easy way
of
dressing and we won't need the dry
cleaner sadly anymore oh i live in hope
if you are a dry cleaner stop putting
everything in plastic drives me mad put
it in paper if you've got to put
anything at all drives me mad it's such
a waste of resources that um and um in
the mail on sunday
nasal sprays i've got to say i
i can't see the appeal of a nasal spray
no but this is a nasal spray that will
fight covid uh it's been developed by a
number of people working for a company
but it's mostly oxford university
scientists again um who have invented
this spray and it contains an active
substance that is lethal to viruses
apparently it kills the covid virus in
30 seconds so if you spray it up your
nose it can give you something like
eight hours protection now they're
saying that if they can bring it to
market it's not a replacement for the
vaccination no way but we do know that
the vaccination doesn't stop you
transmitting covid and this could
because it actually kills off if it's up
your nose um it kills off the the virus
within 30 seconds so it never gets
through to you the virus but also means
you're not breathing it onto other
people as well so it could be an extra
tool to fight kovid with oh well i might
have to change my views on it all uh
look good to see you both this morning
thank you very much indeed all the top
stories coming up just a moment